Hello and welcome to this video on Exercise 2.
And in this, we are going to be using a different animation so
that we can make our smart objects a little bit more modular and
a little bit more reusable.
Now there is a reason why we have so many different classes when we're
setting up a smart object.
And that is so that this can be scalable and modular.
So that we can write one piece of code such as the behavior.
Then we can set up different classes with different settings and
we can reuse that without having to write a whole new piece of code.
Now in this instance, we already have a chair actor,
which has an animation attached to it.
We are going to create a different definition and
have this be controlled by our config.
And we're going to play a different animation so it can function in a slightly different way.
So for example, at the moment we have a floor spot and we have a chair spot.
And as you can see, our chair spot is working fine,
but our floor spot has a completely inappropriate animation.
So I am back in the engine now and I have gone to slide exercise 2,
expose parameter.
Now this should also bring me to the folder for exercise 2 with the different files that we need to edit.
So if we have a look at the files, they're very similar to the ones we had in the previous exercise,
but at the point where we should have finished it.
We have our chair, we have our AI, we have our game behavior sitting down,
and we have our game behavior config sitting down.
And we have two definition files, one for chair and one for floor.
Now if I was to simulate, you'd see that both of our characters work.
They grab their appropriate spots, but our character on the left here is not sitting on the floor,
he's sitting in thin air.
So let's see how we might go about fixing that.
The first thing that I'd like you to do is to open up our GBC sitting down EX2.
And if you come up with this as a data only, just click on the open, open the full blueprint, the blue button at the top.
Now all we need to do in this is add a variable.
So under variables, I'm going to hit plus, and I'm going to call this variable montage.
And on the Boolean dropdown, I am going to look for Ami montage, and I am looking for a object reference.
Now if I hit compile, this will allow me to put a default value in.
Now under the default value in, I'm looking for sitting down.
Because that's our default sitting in a chair.
And that is all I need to do in this, but I am going to close that down.
And the next thing I'm going to do is I'm going to go into the gameplay behavior.
So that is GB sitting down underscore EX2.
Now you should see at the beginning of this file, we have a caption at the beginning here, prompting us to put some code in.
Now we want to get this value from the config file.
So I'm going to pull that out and I'm going to type in cast to, and I am looking for GBC, the config, and we want exercise to.
I'm going to plug that in here.
Now this will give us access to the config.
And if I jump out of here, I can search for montage.
So if I get the montage and we have a variable for the animation montage, which I'm going to plug in here, because this is the variable which is used throughout the system for updating it.
So all we're doing is going to the config and saving whatever is in the config to the variable here to be used in the gameplay behavior.
Now I can save and compile, shut that down.
We just have one thing left to do and that's if we open up the definition file for floor.
So that is SOD underscore floor underscore EX2.
Now you will see in our gameplay definition, we have an option for sitting down.
Now I can override this.
You can see that we have a montage for sitting on the floor.
And if I save that.
Now if we look at the BP floor spot in the smart object, I have already selected that definition file.
So we don't actually need to do anything within the floor spot.
And if I now push simulate, you'll find that the character selects the correct animation for the smart object that they are sitting in.
And that brings us to the end of exercise two.
In the next one, we are going to be looking at using multiple spots to create something slightly more complicated.